why is it so easy for people humans and
animals even we don't even know animals
don't know how to use social media yet
but why is it so easy I love yet it's
coming oh yeah I wouldn't be shocked
that's going to be crazy dude when we
find out the truth about what some of
the animals think
because we've been really we've had kind
of like a lot of set views on animals
for a long time octopus Twitter yeah
yeah I can't wait for that yeah can I
get a piano down here what the [__] do
you think I'm doing with all these arms
um why is it so easy for us to say
something so mean
in a place like social media you know or
to one or it's really crazy because you
wouldn't really do that in person you
wouldn't do that in person because
you're scared of the risk not scared but
you're mindful of the response one time
I posted a picture on Twitter and I was
like it's you know all the we're all
gathered to drive our muscle cars and
they're not muscle cars I know what a
muscle car is they're not really muscle
cars I just have said it you know and
then all these there were all these
nasty comments but they're not muscle
cars I remember my brother read it and
he was genuinely
he was so hurt he was like why are they
being so mean to us we're just driving
our cars we're fine it's like there's a
period where that's where you you don't
understand it's an it's an impersonal
Medium masquerading as a personal medium
right that's the thing and it takes a
little while for you to wrap your head
around the fact that like
no this doesn't matter it's a random it
matters as little as
that you know in the old world that that
person said that same thing but you
didn't hear it
now you hear it and but it's it's just
as trivial it didn't matter it's like
right right but we can't correlate
you're right we can't correlate that
yeah it's real interesting because some
people probably never
recognize that it doesn't matter right
to some people that's their that's their
life that's all that matters yeah I
think it's so that's yeah I think that I
some part of me that's worn off for me
now I care less totally same but I think
it's interesting because yeah that that
used to be chatter in the background
like people saying Ah that's [__]
that's ridiculous that's crazy right or
that's awesome that's great what a great
idea but those were things you heard in
the those are things in the periphery
you never heard you never heard them it
was just the chatter in the distance but
now those are things if you want to
access the chatter in the distance
instead of just having like a somebody
that means something to you communicate
or getting it an interpretation of
something that has from someone that has
value you know or getting even uh like
um even negative feedback but from
someone that you respect you know
um you can get those things still but uh
and those have value but otherwise you
can also tap into all that other [__]
yeah that doesn't but it still hurts the
same yeah you know that's what's
interesting is how much it still it does
yeah it though it's a reminder you know
I think one of the things that we've
and I think I don't think it's new with
social media but it has always been the
case that there is a small there are a
small number of people who
I don't even know whether it's always
deliberate but who Express their
personal unhappiness or their confusion
or their befuddlement
in hostile language
that
and like I said a lot of times I don't
think they mean to be hostile it's just
how it comes out
um a lot of times you know
people who don't communicate for a
living
aren't necessarily expert at adequately
explaining why they'd don't like
something or their reactions to
something they've always been there we
just never heard their voices that's
sort of what we're getting at like
um most people if you I I once conducted
an experiment where
I responded nicely
to people who commented
said nasty things about me on Twitter
and I wanted to see what happened
and what happens when
if they respond again is they almost
invariably back down and you realize
that they didn't actually
mean they didn't mean harm to you or
they weren't actually angry at you or a
hostile they just didn't know how to
express they had a comment they wanted
to make that was
with an issue they have with what you
were saying they just didn't know how to
say it in a way that was kind of
socially
kind of positive or and if you if you're
if you're nice about it and kind of I
used I used to call this um love bombing
and I'm still a big believer in love
bombing so I would love bomb them and I
would just sort of be nice in a response
and they would always like calm down and
they would say yeah you're right you're
kind of right I just I just wondered
about this and you like all of a sudden
you're having a conversation with them
right yeah it's like it's very easy to
disarm 90 of
critics yeah just by kind of taking them
giving them the opportunity to be nicer
about what they're saying I read
somewhere it's almost talking about how
how do kids learn
how to
uh
how do they learn about uh inner social
interactions and if you see this see
this especially with boys
I have a almost two-year-old though
she's a girl not a boy but I actually
see it a little bit with her so when
they when they touch you
they they don't know anything about how
to calibrate their touch so they don't
the difference between a tap and a punch
isn't there yet so you know my
two-year-old will reach out to me and
she'll you know you'll ow right sure and
because she's trying to do a playful
touch my hair playfully but she pulls my
hair she's gonna she wants to touch my
nose but she ends up whacking me in the
nose and what she's getting when I say
ow is feedback
and do that enough times and she learns
she learns how to calibrate her touch
she learns that if she is legit angry
with me she'll go boom but if she wants
to be playful she go tap and you see it
with kids interacting with animals right
they start to learn oh there's a
difference between pulling a tail and
stroking a tail right but you only learn
that if you have repeated
interactions in person where you get to
practice and learn what's acceptable and
what's not when a kid doesn't have
access to that kind of practice then
they don't know how to calibrate right
and there's a whole theory about bullies
the bullies are simply kids who never
who never learn that same process so
they they keep hitting too hard and the
other kids start to ostracize them and
that that means they never they're
they're robbed of that additional
learning it's like a vicious circle and
they don't have any chance to practice
again so they're still in prison so
they're impressive they're like and
they're seven and they're still hitting
too hard and the other kids are like you
know what
I'm not dealing with you at all like you
don't know how to behave right yeah and
I think social media is is a version of
The Bullying you're not getting the
feedback when you're hitting too hard ah
right you're not right there's no that
you say the nasty comment and that's it
you're done no one says ow right which
is one of the reasons why I like to
respond to my critics you do get a
feedback I didn't really mean that or
this is what I mean we had a great time
I'd had a tough day people say stuff
like that I've done that too sometimes
you want to reply to somebody who says
something that's kind of like
they didn't think something was fair
because you want to see what's going on
I genuinely sometimes want to make them
okay yeah and so you'll reply back and
you're right A lot of times it just
extremely de-escalates yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you a one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one